we want to build a company that releases
toys that are educational and
entertaining and we want to do that one
really great toy at a time
my name is Filippo Jakob you know I've
always been a big kid I've always liked
toys I've always liked games and when I
found out that I was gonna be a father I
thought it'd be a good time to start
making toys for a living and I wants to
make educational toys
I think toys have evolved from simple
objects of entertainment into tools for
development for children our
understanding of how children develop
and grow has changed the way that we
look at these tools as well and I think
we're at we're at a point where new
kinds of toys that are truly educational
and entertaining can start being made
because of technologies and I just
wanted to be at the forefront of that
our first toy is called a competitive
playset it's the most crowdfunded
educational technology invention in
kickstarter history it has one a red dot
design award best of best a can lion
goal for product design
it's toured the MoMA in New York City
and MIT and it's a tangible programming
interface for children it's a wooden
robot that merges logo total inspired
programming with Montessori based
hands-on learning so it's a wooden robot
that children can program using blocks
instead of a screen or text I think I'm
I'm fairly self motivated I really want
to make great products and great toys
but I think what kind of gave me the
inspiration and changed my attitude
towards work and design and life in
general was having having my own
children I have a three-year-old son who
was actually born on the day that this
company was launched we would like to
see a competitive play set in each of
the 2.4 million or so early learning
centers and libraries and primary
schools around the world and their new
products we have new products in the
pipeline new services
and expanding the range of products and
services that we can offer to our
community with the same dedication that
we had building this one and sticking to
our principles